nos prestan el 90 por ciento de sus
reservas entonces digamos que aquí están
todos mis bancos banco 1 banco 2 banco 3
puedes imaginarte que llegan incluso
hasta el banco número 100 el problema
con el retiro masivo es que si tan solo
un banco es incapaz de pagarle a sus
depositantes su dinero o sea si no tiene
liquidez no tiene liquidez por el
momento nada más vamos a decir que no
tiene liquidez y no diremos nada de su
solvencia pero bueno si no es líquido
entonces todos los depositantes de los
otros bancos se espantan y corren por su
dinero correspondiente al banco ahora
por definición en un sistema bancario de
reserva fraccionaria estos bancos sólo
tienen el 10% y el 10% de los depósitos
como reservas 10% en reservas entonces
si todas las personas piden más del 10
por ciento de su dinero ninguno va a
tener liquidez ninguno tendrá liquidez
el problema es que aquí se va a ser un
montón de pánico va a haber un gran
pánico en el sistema financiero tan
pronto algunos
de estos bancos se ven más déjame
dibujar la hoja de balance y supongamos
que son buenos inversionistas que es una
gran suposición pero bueno su hoja de
balance se ve así
esto de acá son depósitos que nos deben
a las personas como a ti y guaminí esos
son sus pasivos y tienen 10 por ciento
de sus activos en reserva 10 por ciento
como reserva algo así eso de ahí son las
reservas y el resto todo el resto de sus
activos son préstamos que hicieron
algunas empresas o lo que sean préstamos
a algunos negocios
esos son activos porque los negocios le
deben ese dinero al banco ahora qué
sucede en cuanto hay pánico todo el
mundo quiere su dinero y las reservas se
agotan bien rápido tenemos que las
reservas las reservas se agotan bien
rápido para entonces estos monitos se
van a quedar ahí esperando prácticamente
cierran el banco y en cuanto se paguen
estas deudas no sé por ejemplo digamos
que esta tarda un año dentro de un año
el banco va a obtener su dinero y ya no
va a poder renovar el préstamo ya con el
dinero va a poder pagarle
a todos ya no hay préstamos se cae el
sistema el crédito se congela el pánico
va a causar un congelamiento del crédito
congelamiento del crédito y recuerda
esto es un gran problema pudo haber sido
casado tan solo por un mal banco que no
pudo controlar sus problemas de liquidez
o peor aún pudo haber sido causado tan
solo por un cliente que entró en pánico
por alguna razón o sea podría hacer que
algún miedo entre al sistema e incluso
para un banco totalmente legítimo y deja
de poner legítimo entre comillas porque
pues muchas personas podrían argumentar
que el sistema de banca de reserva
fraccionaria pues en realidad no es
legítimo pero bueno incluso aunque éste
sea un banco que tiene todo en orden si
por alguna razón más del 10% de sus
clientes se espantan entonces va a tener
un problema de liquidez y caemos en esta
situación horrible de pánico ahora en el
vídeo pasado hablé de algunas de las
cosas que se ingeniaron para resolver
este problema estos de aquí son los
remedios uno es tener un prestamista así
como de último recurso un prestamista de
último recurso ese de ahí va a ser el
banco central o bien el banco de la
reserva federal
el banco de la reserva federal
recordemos que a este banco nunca se le
van a acabar las reservas porque estas
reservas estas reservas se le pueden
pedir prestadas y todos estos son
pagarés son pagarés pero del gobierno
federal de la reserva federal
entonces lo que hace el banco de la
reserva federal y creo que ya platicamos
mucho de esto supongamos que su hoja de
balance
inicialmente se ve así aquí están sus
pasivos por acá tenemos los activos sus
pasivos por el aumento casi todos van a
ser pagarés son estas notas de la
reserva pero supongamos que alguien
llega y dice el banco de la reserva
préstame algo de dinero si préstame y lo
que van a hacer es que van a imprimir
algunas notas de la reserva federal
estas de aquí son notas de la reserva
federal y van a crear un pasivo
correspondiente y recordemos que ellos
no tienen límite es verdad déjame lo
pongo con otro color para que no esté
tan aburrido esto entonces van a tener
este pasivo correspondiente de notas
pendientes y esos billetes te los van a
dar a ti le van a dar los billetes al
banco que está en la situación
desesperada de que nadie le quiere
prestar dinero muy bien entonces la hoja
de balance ahora se va a ver así así es
como se veía antes ahora tiene unas
nuevas notas pendientes notas pendientes
a esta parte en vez de decir notas de la
reserva federal va a decir esta nueva
cosa que es préstamo al banco préstamo a
este banco de acá que es un activo
porque el banco le debe dinero ahora
recordemos que el banco de la reserva no
tiene límite para hacer esto claro a lo
mejor hay algunos límites implícitos no
sé tal vez por alguna razón la gente
decide arbitrariamente que los billetes
así ya no tienen nada de valor pero
sería pues la principal preocupación y
después hablaremos de que otras razones
hacen que el banco federal no puede
expedir esto ilimitadamente pero bueno
podemos pensar que no se le acaba
entonces tenemos esta idea de
prestamista de último recurso pero a lo
mejor al banco de la reserva no le
conviene pues este banco a lo mejor este
banco es pues esencialmente insolvente
sus préstamos fueron malos estos
préstamos que hizo son súper malos hasta
empiezan a apestar entonces pues
realmente no debería haber ninguna razón
para que el banco central le prestará a
este banco vaya el banco de la reserva
puede ver las inversiones de este banco
y decirle sabes que sus préstamos no
valen nada la verdad no te voy a prestar
dinero lo que
a hacer es que te vamos a declarar en
quiebra y creo que ni siquiera he
hablado acerca de eso este es el segundo
remedio el segundo remedio es tener esta
noción de un seguro un seguro a los
depósitos en méxico tenemos el ipab
seguro de los depósitos
entonces si el banco nada más tuvo
problemas de liquidez y es un buen banco
de japón go bueno entre comillas buen
banco que se le acabaron las reservas y
ningún otro banco está dispuesto a
prestarle que es raro verdad estamos
diciendo que es un buen banco pero nadie
quiere prestarle pero bueno entonces
puede ir a la ventanilla de descuento
del banco de la reserva federal y pedir
prestado sin embargo si la situación es
más grave y el banco está en la quiebra
déjame hacer el ejemplo de eeuu entonces
le ha pagado a la jefe dice cierta
cantidad de dinero a la federal
depósito
insurance corporation insurance
corporation un poquito de dinero bueno a
lo mejor mucho dinero para una persona
pero poquito dinero para un banco es un
porcentaje pequeño pero bueno un poquito
de dinero cada año de modo que le pueda
decir a sus clientes mira
incluso en la situación en la que yo no
te pueda pagar nada te va a pagar el
gobierno federal a través de la fed y se
vaya todo tu dinero está respaldado por
la fcc no importa que le suceda al banco
ahora para mí esto sí es un gran remedio
la verdad si yo viviera en eeuu tendría
todos mis ahorros en bancos asegurados
por la fd hice cuentas bancarias
aseguradas por la fdc ahora esto está
fantástico para los clientes pero cuál
es el efecto en el sistema bancario pues
voy a volver a dibujar los bancos para
ver esto tenemos el banco 1 banco 2
banco 3 y banco 4
todos ellos están asegurados por la fdic
es decir pagan un cierto porcentaje de
sus ganancias cada año y entonces le
pueden decir a sus clientes mira sabes
que no importa si entramos en quiebra oa
cualquier otro lío todos tus depósitos
están seguros están 100% seguros y que
va a suceder esto resuelve lo de los
retiros masivos cierto supongamos que
por alguna razón a este banco se le
acaban las reservas o entra en
bancarrota este banco entra en
bancarrota y en la situación anterior
todo el mundo se espantaba eso generaba
un retiro masivo y eso era un problema
grandísimo porque cuando la gente
pidiera el dinero no iba a haber porque
sólo había un porcentaje en reservas así
funciona la reserva fraccionaria pero
ahora todo el mundo va a estar tranquilo
porque hay un respaldo federal un
respaldo que puede imprimir la cantidad
de dinero que quiera y entonces esto
efectivamente resuelve el problema
resuelve el problema de los retiros
masivos muy bien esto arregla el
problema del equilibrio inestable pero
que otros efectos secundarios tienen
pues ve todos estos bancos están
igualmente asegurados por la fed
y entonces yo me siento tranquilo de
depositar en cualquiera en cual lo voy a
acabar depositando entonces pues en el
que me dé más interés voy a depositar en
el que me dé más interés mayor interés
esto lo hace a cada rato una tía que
vive por ella en eeuu va y deposita su
dinero en el que le da más interés
ignorando completamente en donde está
invirtiendo el banco antes no haría eso
porque a lo mejor hubiera pensado que es
algo como que oscuro o arriesgado pero
ahora como life dice asegura todos los
bancos seguro le devuelven el dinero que
sucede pues mi tía deposita en el banco
que da mayor interés ahora por lo que
platicamos en el vídeo pasado cual es el
banco que va a dar mayor interés pues
justo es el banco que está tomando un
mayor riesgo que está tomando la mayor
cantidad de riesgo entonces una vez más
cuando das este seguro que es
relativamente barato
seguro barato y lo que hace que los
bancos puedan jalar mucho más personas
teniendo este seguro sí verdad si no
tuvieran este seguro entonces tendrían
que pagar no sé digamos que este seguro
cuesta no sé punto 1 por ciento por año
si no tuvieran este seguro entonces
tendrían que pagar mucho más que punto
uno por ciento más a sus clientes pues
los clientes estarían corriendo
demasiado riesgo ya que su dinero no
estaría respaldado por el gobierno
entonces está re bueno para los bancos
no mira cuando tú depositas en un banco
prácticamente le estás haciendo un
préstamo donde el interés es cuánto te
paga tu cuenta de cheques lo escribo tu
tasa de interés de la cuenta de depósito
de la cuenta de depósito es exactamente
lo mismo del precio que paga el banco
por tomar prestado si voy a un banco y
me da del 2% anual es el costo de tomar
prestado del banco el costo del banco de
tomar prestado es exactamente lo mismo
entonces si el banco no tiene un seguro
de la fdic entonces ya no tendría que
pagar
1 % sin embargo en compensación a mí me
tendría que dar tres o cuatro por ciento
de interés para compensar el riesgo pues
claro verdad es mucho más riesgoso que
alguien que puede imprimir el dinero que
tendría que pagar más pero tan sólo
pagando punto 1% al año más pagando
punto 1 por ciento
bueno punto 1 lo que sea que la fed se
decida que es un buen precio para cobrar
por este seguro que usualmente es mucho
más bajo que lo que tiene que pagar en
diferencia pero bueno pagando ese punto
1 por ciento o lo que sea obtenemos que
a fin de cuentas va a reducir lo que le
tiene que pagar a sus clientes porque
ahora entonces mucho menos riesgoso de
lo que pensaban inicialmente entonces va
a disminuir el precio del préstamo va a
disminuirlo por mucho más por mucho más
que punto uno por ciento entonces está
súper padrísimo el negocio para el banco
de hecho para quién es más negocio es
para los bancos riesgosos ahora nada más
tienen que pagar un poquito más pero
pagando eso pueden hacer cosas así súper
mega ultra arriesgadas y puedes decirme
bueno la fd y se está haciendo un poco
estúpida aquí debería de cobrarle
a los bancos que se arriesgan más pero
bueno mi respuesta es que es mucho más
fácil decirlo que hacerlo recordemos que
cuando los tiempos son buenos cuando los
tiempos son buenos digamos los años
veintes en los eeuu o antes de la
burbuja hipotecaria pues el riesgo está
escondido así debajo de las piedras
está totalmente escondido así que pues
realmente no sabemos quién está tomando
todo el riesgo pero a lo mejor son los
que están ganando más uno nunca sabe
pero en ese momento no se ve como
siempre pueden pagar uno puede pensar
que son genios esta persona se ve como
un genio cuando los tiempos están buenos
pero cuando empeoran las cosas cuando
empeoran las cosas todo sale mal pero
este genio se salva porque la fd y se le
paga su chistecito y seguro todo el
tiempo le estuvo cobrando de menos bueno
quiero hacer un último punto acerca de
esto recordemos que esta es efe que es
la insurance corporation insurance
corporation pero lo que quiero marcar es
la diferencia entre un seguro financiero
por ejemplo los swaps de incumplimiento
crediticio de otro de mis vídeos la
diferencia entre un seguro financiero y
el concepto usual que tenemos de seguro
no sé
pongamos como ejemplo una aseguradora de
autos mira supongamos que tenemos un
montón de conductores por aquí tenemos
al conductor uno al conductor dos
conductor tres
conductor 4 y supongamos que cualquiera
de ellos cada año tiene un 10% de
probabilidad de tener un accidente eso
es mucho más alto de lo de la vida real
pero es para que los números hagan
facilitos y supongamos que un accidente
me cuesta 10 mil pesos 10 mil pesos
entonces poner con el conductor 1 y
decirle mira hay un 10% de probabilidad
de que tengas un accidente ese accidente
te costaría 10 mil pesos así que lo
justo sería que te cobrará 1000 pero te
voy a cobrar mil 100 va te cobro 1100
pues para que yo tengo una ganancia va
si quisiera quedar tablas tendría que
cobrar 1000 pero voy a cobrar 1100 y
claro podría hacer esto en vez de con
cuatro conductores pues digamos con
cuatro mil entonces en promedio así en
un año específico no sé supongamos que
tengo que tengo un millón de conductores
un millón de conductores entonces en un
año cuánto dinero me va a entrar a ver
es un millón por mil 100 eso es 1100
millones de ingresos eso de ahí sería mi
ingreso y cuánto voy a tener que pagar
cuánto dinero va a tener que salir
entonces el pago total
bueno pues creyéndonos la estadística
aproximadamente el 10 por ciento así que
serían 100 mil personas que se van a
accidentar 100 mil accidentes cada uno
me salen diez mil diez mil por cien
miles mil millones de pesos voy a pagar
mil millones de pesos y así si mis
estadísticas están bien porque mis
actuarios hicieron bien su trabajo voy a
tener una ganancia de 100 millones sale
todo esto funciona muy bien claro si las
estadísticas están bien porque si
tenemos un montón de conductores como un
millón por la ley de los grandes números
todos se comportan más o menos así la
probabilidad de que digamos 20% de los
conductores tengan un accidente es muy
muy muy pequeña
prácticamente cero además que un
conductor tenga un accidente no causa
que por otro lado otro conductor también
lo tenga falla los accidentes de
distintos conductores son independientes
entre sí
esta hipótesis se da en otros contextos
como seguros de desempleo o de salud con
esta hipótesis la estadística se cumple
pero en pero para seguros financieros
pasa algo muy distinto no sé podríamos
tener una estadística de la fdc de que
en promedio en promedio o sea en un año
de un año en promedio la fd y se puede
decir mira yo creo que sólo uno de cada
tres mil bancos falla o sea que un banco
tiene un punto 1 por ciento de
probabilidad de ser una pérdida total
bueno no total porque en realidad el
banco tiene algunos activos pero no
podemos trabajar como antes porque ahora
las fallas bancarias suelen estar
correlacionadas falla el sistema
bancario está muy entrelazado no sé
alguno podría estar prestándole a este
negocio que depende de este negocio al
que le está prestando este otro banco
todo está súper entrelazado entonces las
fallas pues no son falla están
correlacionadas
no es independiente si un banco falla es
mucho más probable que otros bancos
también empiecen a fallar justo eso fue
lo que empezó a pasar en eeuu hace
algunos años pero bueno entonces lo que
nos dice esto es que no podemos seguir
el modelo tradicional el modelo
tradicional de seguros así en el cual
las cosas no están correlacionadas
porque acá cuando todos los eventos
empiezan a fallar de manera
correlacionada lo que tienes es en los
buenos tiempos una tasa de pérdida mucho
más baja pero en los malos tiempos vas a
ver que todo empieza a fallar y entonces
básicamente vas a estar pendiendo de un
hilo justo como pasó hace algunos años
con la fd y se tuvo que regresar al
congreso y pedir más dinero y finalmente
eso acabó pues recayendo en la gente que
paga sus impuestos